I'm really pleased to have Dr Joe Rankin here today to talk about her new book,
um,
a people's history of computing in the United States.
And I got that right.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I sort of discovered the book,
you know,
browsing on the web and it,
it talked about sort of early computing experiences and I really connected with
basic,
which is,
which is going to come up a lot in the book.
Um,
I started programming in basic and you know,
like a home computer or when I was a kid and,
uh,
really enjoyed,
um,
a book called 101 basic computer games that were very simple games.
And,
and it's interesting that,
uh,
as it became a professional programmer,
I mostly spend time think about how,
um,
how much,
I didn't really approve of basic,
it was not a serious language,
right?
Uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
in like in thinking about it or reading the book,
I came to remember how much fun it was and how,
like,
how you turned on a computer and there was basic in front of you,
right?
Like,
you know,
you immediately got the interpreter prompter and that was pretty amazing.
And I thought the message of the book lined up so well with the three respects.
We're trying to think about it.
Google,
um,
one respect the user since this is really all about letting users a program the
computer and interact with it more directly.
And I thought this book was particularly interesting when we think about,
um,
respecting the opportunity because we have a big business that um,
you know,
sells computing to,
to consumers.
You know,
we either pay through ads or through the cloud computing business,
um,
and that's kind of intention or,
or you know,
uh,
the business relationship is a little bit intention with empowering people to
create whatever they want.
Now,
clearly clouds sort of supports that as well.
But the,
um,
I think the early idea of search was to make the web more powerful,
right?
That as the web got better,
uh,
Google got better and as Google have better,
we made the web better for people.
And I think there's a little bit of a tension between that and a and running a
large corporation and then a profitable business.
And I thought some of the stories you had to tell really help remind us of how
many people are creators and,
and how much creativity we can unlock when we,
when we really think about them and the opportunities we create for them.
Um,
so that's,
that's why I was so excited to have you come and talk about this book.
Uh,
so Dr Rankin is a historian,
uh,
but in chatting with her today,
I found out she was also a math major at Dartmouth.
She has written some crypto code.
Uh,
so I think she brings a really interesting perspective to the whole story.
So let me turn it over to her.
Thank you Jeremy for that introduction and thank you all being here today.
I am so excited to have the opportunity to speak with you and speak with Google.
I am just going to jump right in.
All right.
So in 1958,
Tom Kurtz wanted to run a computer program that I hear is Tom Kurtz.
Circa 1958 so to do this,
to run his computer program,
he woke up early one morning and traveled about five miles from his home in
Hanover,
New Hampshire to White River junction,
Vermont.
He carried with him a steel box that looked like this one.
And when he got to White River junction,
Vermont,
he boarded the six 20 morning train to Boston,
Boston.
He trades the train for a taxi to get to the computer center at Mit.
Finally,
finally at Mit is computer center.
He opens the box that he carries with him and it contains hundreds of cardboard
cards.
So some of those cards very carefully ordered and wrapped with an elastic band
are his computer program.
Other cards contain the programs of his colleagues at Dartmouth College where he
is a professor in the math department.
So Dartmouth is a small liberal arts college during the 1950s it doesn't have
its own computer.
So,
uh,
the Dartmouth professors use the computing resources at Mit.
So curt's hands his stack of punched cards over to the operator at the MIT
computer center and walks away hours later.
At the end of the day,
he goes back to the computer center to pick up his cards and pick out,
pick up the very precious printout results of his computer program and it gets
on the train back home and he sees of course some error messages.
What does this mean?
Well,
it means he's going to have to revise his program,
repunched the cards and repeat this process all over again two weeks later.
So I love starting with the story because it shows that individual access to
computing in 1958 was so rare and so valuable that Tom Kurtz was willing to
spend a whole day to receive a few minutes,
maybe a few seconds of access to computing.
And it also really shows Tom's perspective as a user.
So this brings me to my research.
The question that guides my research is what does it mean to write histories of
computing and of technology from the user?
My book a people's history of computing in the United States answers that
question.
The people in this people's history,
our students and educators,
people like Tom Kurtz who built and used academic computing networks during the
1960s and the 1970s so mine is a history of our digital age that really
emphasizes creativity and collaboration and community.
So for the next 15 minutes or so,
I'm going to tell you how Kurtz and thousands of other students and educators
built a computing network that's spanned new England during the 1960s and I want
to show you how computing was interwoven in their daily lives.
It was part of their status,
their sports,
their dates they're dating and their gaming.
And finally I will conclude with an opportunity.
So all that time on the train got Kurds to thinking there has to be a better way
to do this.
And a few years after that 1958 train ride,
he proposed a better way of computing to a fellow math professor at Dartmouth,
John Kemeny.
And Kurt's pitched three related ideas.
First,
all students at the college should have access to computing.
And this is important,
not just the scientists or the engineers,
the mathematicians,
but everyone,
regardless of what they were studying,
he also advocated that computing should be free for the students,
not something they would have to pay for.
And finally,
he thought the first two things could be accomplished by a then mode of
computing known as time sharing.
So what's timesharing timesharing as a form of computing in which multiple
terminals,
multiple users are simultaneously connected to a single mainframe computer.
It's a network because they're connected by phone lines.
Um,
so and that,
and not necessarily a network like we think of today,
but all of those terminals can still communicate with each other via the
mainframe.
Um,
the terminals are connected to the mainframe by long distance phone lines or
local phone lines as the case may be.
And the terminals look like this.
Um,
so they're teletype writers are teletypes originally used for telegraphy then
used for computing and like an old fashioned typewriter with a printer attached.
So users would enter their programs,
see them sort of printed out,
and then the computer would communicate back to the user by printing out a
program results on the teletype writer.
So what this means is an individual user is able to write and debug a program in
minutes,
not hours or weeks.
So when Kurt's,
I'm Kemeny seek funding for their network,
what they emphasize is that at most other university competing centers during
the 1960s those universities are focused on maximizing the resources of the
computer computers,
very large,
very expensive.
The most efficient thing to do is to keep them running as much as possible,
but that doesn't do a lot of good for the people using the computers.
Instead,
Kemeny and Kurt say we want to build a network that will be most convenient for
that user to enable as much creativity and productivity as possible for those
users.
Rather than maximizing the efficiency of the computer,
they get their funding.
Kurt's writes a series of memos to guide the development efforts.
And at this point I should say,
this network is programmed and developed by Dartmouth undergraduate students.
And Kurtz specifies,
and this is a quote in all cases where there is a choice between simplicity and
efficiency.
Simplicity is chosen.
Every effort will be made to design a system convenient for the user.
So I love this because clearly this is respect for the user and this is what it
looks like for Kemeny and Kurds circa 1963 and at this point,
I'm just going to say at the Dartmouth system,
the network was wildly popular.
It was implemented in 1964 by 1968 on campus,
80% of the students are regularly using the network,
they know basic and they program comfortably.
Um,
and 40% of the faculty are regularly using the network and basic.
But,
and this is equally important,
this sort of generic idea,
just the word user on the Dartmouth network shows that that word mass,
social and cultural hierarchies and norms and expectations,
especially around gender.
So Kemeny and Kurt's designed their time sharing network because they believed
that their students who were all men during the 1960s,
Dartmouth is still men only as an undergraduate institution.
And during the 1960s,
Dartmouth is almost exclusively white as an institution,
that those white men would be the future leaders of the United States.
And they thought that computing was essential to their future leadership of the
United States.
They also envisioned computing as an equalizer among their students.
That all of the students having that access for free would be something of an
equal opportunity.
But this student saw it differently.
The students who had programmed the network and continue to develop and maintain
it really created a space and hierarchy for themselves based on their
familiarity with that system.
So they mocked their peers who thought of the teletypes as computers or her
complained.
If a teletype wasn't working,
that the computer wasn't working and they played practical jokes,
um,
substituting strings of meaningless,
meaningless text into the output of a program that somebody had spent hours or
days writing.
These programmer in student peers,
however,
were United in their enthusiasm for football played on the field and on the
network.
So football to say that football dominated Dartmouth's culture during the 1960s
is a bit of an understatement.
Dartmouth,
uh,
won the Ivy League championship several times and really the campus,
and football went hand in hand as cultures and there were several versions of
football FTB a l l like this was one of them that were developed and played on
the network including a multiplayer version.
Um,
so the popularity of the football on the network,
uh,
really mirrored the celebration of this very masculine macho sport on campus.
The football games also provided an opportunity from women from nearby all
women's colleges to travel to Hanover to socialize with the Dartmouth men.
And many men recalled that they brought their dates to the campus computing
centers before or after the games to like show off their computing prowess or
show off their gaming expertise.
Even though several of those women's colleges were also part of the Dartmouth
Network,
which meant the women themselves were also computing as well.
So in the course of my research,
I was repeatedly struck by how many Dartmouth men wanted to tell me and did tell
me stories about computing in connection with dating and how they really were
reinforcing existing gender roles with their computing.
So one told me,
he used the teletype to print out this huge banner that said,
hey girl and all caps,
hey girl,
I miss you.
And he rolled up the huge banner and put it in a poster tube and mailed it to
his then girlfriend who was attending college in New York.
And now they've been married for almost 50 years.
And this is one example like I could get,
I'm happy to give you more during Qa.
Um,
but what do I mean by gender roles here?
So remember we're talking the 1960s the cold war nuclear family was the norm,
right?
This idea that there's a breadwinner,
father and to domestic mother staying at home and some kids in suburbia,
and we can see this even with competing.
So John Kemeny goes on to become president of Dartmouth college and in 1966 the
college's dedicating its brand new computing center and he gives a keynote
speech at the dedication and he talks about how great it will be when everyone
has terminals in their homes.
At this point,
some faculty already have terminal and that terminals in their homes as part of
the network.
Any talks about how his wise using the terminals to do things like program their
chores and planned balance diets and meals for their families and do their
shopping online.
And those are the,
that's the way that he sees women using computing.
But while he's talking about housewives using computing to prepare balanced
meals,
there are women working at Dartmouth in that computer center in key roles.
Um,
there was a disconnect there.
So Janet Price,
Diane Hills,
Diane Mather,
they're all doing various kinds of applications,
programming,
coding,
Nancy broadhead manages user services.
Um,
the two Diane's are also managing the software library.
And the examples go on.
I bring this up because these women were not exceptions to the norm,
but rather represented the range of possibilities for women doing professional
computing in the United States in the 1960s
and as I mentioned,
many of the college women themselves had access to computing at their own
colleges.
They too are doing this personal computing,
this social networking through the Dartmouth network during the 1960s.
The network encompass tens of colleges and high schools from Connecticut to
Maine.
So this is a map of about 20 of the high schools that were connected to the
network during the 1960s some were in very poor rural farming communities.
Others were elite,
prestigious,
affluent boarding schools,
a huge range.
The students,
however,
everywhere they loved the network,
they loved programming and creating and basic.
They kept their teletypes running 12 hours a day,
six days a week.
Some of them even woke up at four o'clock in the morning.
High school areas like high schoolers waking up at four o'clock voluntarily just
because they want to get on the network and that's when they can do it.
They created a multitude of imaginative games and programs.
These are just some of the examples.
High School newspaper layout,
battle ship bullying and more.
But
once again,
this attempt to sort of provide equal access,
equal opportunities through computing.
It didn't quite pan out that way.
Why?
Well,
boys and young men had much more access to the Dartmouth network then girls.
So during the 1960s,
every single private school that was connected to the network was boys only.
And those private schools had 72 hours of teletype access each week compared to
the 40 hours for pride or for public schools.
So why is it a private schools have almost double the access time,
the network time being shared with compared with a public school.
Boys and girls and the boys are often in sort of newsletters about the program
reports.
The boys are more often recognized for their programs even though girls are
still writing these programs as well.
So again,
keep in mind the 1960s although Korea expectations and educational opportunities
for girls and women,
we changed dramatically in the next decade.
During the 1960s most of the girls attending these public schools in New England
works back to be homemakers,
um,
and to marry young.
And at the time,
high school boys were enrolling in many more math and science classes.
Then girls and the girls were just not encouraged in computing,
even if they were interested,
but make no mistake,
they were still competing.
So,
for example,
13 year old Giulia Hawthorne,
um,
wrote a game of checkers and basic,
and there are more examples.
It's just that the girls and women were not recognized.
It recognized or supported as much as the boys and men and the Cold War gender
norms helped a race,
their contribution contribution.
So to us now,
50 years later,
all of this seems a little bit remarkable.
So
Tom Kurtz and John Kemeny,
as I said,
they envisioned competing as an equalizer.
I think they were trying to implement a version of respect each other with this
idea of computing for all.
But that's not how it played out because society was not equal,
right?
There are different expectations we can clearly see for boys and girls,
men and women and different levels of access and resources and recognition for
everyone involved.
So here I see the opportunity to recognize that computing was not divorced from
the culture in which it arose Kemeny and carts and their students,
they built the network with people like themselves in mind.
And ditto for all of the students who created basic programs.
They were thinking about themselves and their friends.
And that is absolutely understandable,
but it also points to the fact that technology is not a thing apart from society
talking about tech people or separating out tech companies.
That's a false dichotomy because it's always people who are creating,
who are inventing,
who are problem solving and moonshining and it's almost always that they're
doing those things with other people in mind.
Even if that's not explicitly stated.
And often still the people who aren't recognized as Techie,
the girls writing the basic programs,
teachers,
cultivating computing communities,
the women behind the scenes at Dart,
Miss Computer Center,
there's still doing crucial technological work.
So today,
all too often we talk about things,
right?
We talk about our computers and our devices,
the Internet,
the web,
the algorithm,
and that makes all of those things seem disconnected from us,
from the people who create them and use them and transform them.
So there's the opportunity by focusing on computing rather than computers,
we gain a completely different picture of technology.
Will you listen for and hear the voices not usually heard.
And we search for and find the stories that had been overlooked are never told
in the first place.
And we remember that technology has always been about people.
Thanks.
We'll switch it back to them and multiple cameras and
I think we need,
need a second microphone.
Okay.
I will going to commit some notes.
So,
so I prepared a few questions.
You would of course love to have your questions to
see if we can control the camera.
I'll start with a couple of mine since I haven't
a little time to think in advance about them.
Um,
and you know,
if anyone does want to ask a question,
just,
uh,
feel free to jump in.
I,
I guess,
I mean you talked a lot about gender and you're talking,
I mentioned earlier the
how we do I guess tend to forget about the role of women in computing in the
60s.
So for example,
uh,
my advisor,
got his start working on cts ass and then went on to work on Baltics.
And so I've read a bunch of those papers,
but it actually wasn't until I read your book,
did I realize that?
I think the second author on the CCSS paper was a woman,
Marjorie.
Everyone used initials back then,
so I only ever recognized her by her last name.
Right.
And uh,
and so yeah,
that was a little invisible to me.
Um,
so you talk about how it's connected to people.
I feel sometimes like a society and culture has moved farther ahead than maybe
computing has,
right?
So we have,
uh,
I think more problems with equity like in the industry than we do in society at
large.
Like I wonder if you think that's fair or you know,
if there's a reason for that,
right.
Is this somehow competing didn't keep up with the rest of society usually we
think of competing being ahead.
Right?
Yeah.
I see.
I actually,
I feel like what I'm about to say sounds pessimistic,
but I think right now at this moment,
in some ways in this cultural moment society,
um,
is maybe about where sort of technology is,
and that they're inseparable.
I was listening to a podcast the other day and one of the speakers said that in
technology and stem more broadly,
there's not a pipeline problem.
It's not about getting women in because there have always been women doing
science and technology and computing.
It's a gender problem.
It's sort of how we think about what is normal and expected of men of women,
not just in culture broadly but in particular cases.
Part of why I love the Dartmouth case is because you really see this creation
of,
of masculine around football,
around playing computing pranks around the fact that there are women working in
all sorts of ways in tech and still the college president is talking about like
women doing their grocery shopping.
So I think there's work to be done,
um,
in tech and in society and really thinking about the kinds of cultures
or micro cultures,
maybe corporate cultures and how they both mirror what's happening in society as
well as how they might be a room to sort of steer and shift changes in society
as well.
Maybe also mention as set up to
this question,
um,
the book talks about more than Dartmouth and basic,
you know,
and I thought that was really fascinating to see sort of the range of early
computer networks and what they were like.
So there was a,
um,
there's this great network at Illinois built around a computer with like a
plasma display in a touch screen.
Yeah.
MMM.
You know,
which is 75.
Right?
Yeah.
Which was really impressive.
And um,
and a network of,
uh,
Minnesota that was,
run by the state for all the schools in the state.
Um,
and
I guess I was curious to what extent did you explore,
or how maybe the gender roles were different in some of those places.
I know when you talk about Illinois in the book,
the one example of use of sort of the teaching software that's developed was a
woman developing coursework for nursing students.
I guess she happened to be the husband of the crater or the partner or the
creator of the system.
But was that different by virtue of the nature of what it was used for and the
student population or,
or not?
I think it's the same sort of unusual juxtaposition of the fact that,
so this network,
uh,
centered at the University of Illinois,
he called Plato is originally,
it starts as a network that's focused on education,
like computer assisted instruction.
Um,
and so in trying to develop this system,
they're working with,
uh,
men and women experts from all sorts of different fields.
And as a result,
you end up with people like Marianne Bitzer who is creating nursing education
for our students.
But as a result also becoming,
she's doing technological work.
Uh,
there's another woman,
Valerie Lamont,
who actually creates a program that's related to environmental pollution and
Urbana Champagne.
And again,
she's a political scientist,
but doing this technological communicative work.
Um,
and so I think what we see with Plato and I talk about this a bit in the book,
is that there's a space for these women to sort of do things that,
that are defined the sort of cultural norm.
But at the same time,
the network itself and the way that it's spoken about more broadly in society
sort of does things like reinforce gender norms.
So for instance,
there,
it's an amazing resource.
There are four years of their notes files,
which were like their digital bulletin board and they preserved them.
And you can go online and sort of read through four years of people's
interactions on a message board.
And those clearly show sort of women complaining about harassment,
like women who are working on the system,
who are experts,
they're treated differently than the men.
So it's this,
it's this push and pull this tension of,
ah,
we've got a space for women,
um,
to do the technological work,
but it's not recognized.
And they're often because of the culture sort of not even sort of,
they are,
they're harassed,
they're marginalized,
they're not recognized.
Yeah.
I guess the kind of mix of aggressions and microaggressions.
I,
you know,
that I,
I know my colleagues here face when we're developing software today.
So I guess yeah,
it turned out to be a little sad that like the same sort of gender stereotypes
continued to play out today.
You know,
I think we,
we,
we have more awareness today,
so maybe we can do better,
but I don't know that we're actually doing a lot better yet.
Yeah.
And it mean to,
you know,
today,
I think it,
it sort of plays out in right in media representations of,
and I talk about this a bit in my book was sort of Silicon Valley mythology or
the sort of idea that like all technology is created by like a few white guys
and everyone in this room,
I'm sure everyone at Google knows that's not the case.
You're all like living and breathing,
um,
evidence of that,
but still sort of,
I think in media coverage,
popular culture,
it's a,
it's a still a different idea and it's one that kind of privileges,
you know,
Pale males.
Yeah.
Um,
I also wanted to ask,
uh,
a little bit about this notion of computing citizenship that you talk about.
Uh,
which I thought was pretty interesting and,
and played out in all of the places that,
um,
uh,
I guess at Dartmouth it was about being a good user,
right?
And you know,
sharing things but not using too much space for your programs that were not
worth sharing.
Uh,
and you sort of contrast that with the citizenship and community with sort of a
consumer culture maybe that came with the PC.
Right now we want to sell a PC into your home.
It's a thing you buy and it comes with software on it,
but it doesn't have the same sharing.
I mean,
maybe you could say a little bit more about that.
Ah,
so when I was on the journey of researching and writing this book,
I really sort of thinking from user up for a while I struggled because I was
like,
oh,
very clearly,
very quickly it became clear to me like,
these aren't just users.
They are,
they're writing software,
they're creating games,
they're figuring out how to do social networking.
In the 1960s and I debated like,
am I going to call them authors?
You know,
they're writing or coding or they programmers are they makers?
And none of that seemed right.
And over the course of my writing I realized,
well,
what's essential is they're all part of these communities and those community
there,
they're focused on collaboration and sort of at their most ideal,
there is this idea of computing for the public good computing as a collective
resource.
And so I thought of the idea of competing citizenship as a way to say they are
citizens of these computing communities.
They are participating and it's not a political scientist idea of Def,
uh,
idea of citizenship.
Although in some ways they're closely related in terms of who is recognized to,
is supported,
um,
who gets a voice in the network and on the network.
And so when I started thinking about citizenship as a way to talk about their
participation,
and also I should say to emphasize all of the public institutions that
underwrote all of this networking right there,
local and state and federal governments,
the National Science Foundation colleges and public universities,
they're all pouring money into these computing that works.
So here's another way that sort of citizenship comes into play.
Well
over the course of the 1980s and really with the introduction of personal
computers or hung computers,
there's no more as there is this idea of like,
oh,
computing might be something we have as a public utility,
which there was very much this idea that like there was gonna be a public
competing utility in the 1960s or seventies and instead it became this idea of
know everyone's going to go out and they're going to buy a computer,
they're going to buy a device,
they're going to buy software.
Whereas in the sixties and seventies the communities I'm talking about are
saying,
no,
no.
We share our son.
We share our basic,
like basic is freely available to whoever wants it.
We publish basic programs,
we circulate them.
And so to me,
I saw it's sort of,
it's a foreclosure of opportunity to this shift from saying our computing could
be for the public good.
It could be a public utility,
it could be regulated by the government,
um,
for better or perhaps for worse to this idea of no,
no,
everyone should go by,
by a computer,
by device,
by some software that limits things.
It certainly
makes the distribution of computing less equal.
Right?
Because you,
you,
you know,
you need to have the affluence to afford to go buy a computer.
Right.
And,
and if you want to connect to someone else,
you have to pay yourself a,
for the network access.
I was,
I was struck by how expensive it was,
uh,
to be part of a network.
And that was actually mostly telephone charges.
And,
and you talked about how the state of Minnesota like pooled its resources and
they were able to negotiate with the telephone company for better rates and
better tech knowledgey.
Yeah.
And I,
I mean,
I love,
I love the Minnesota case.
So Minnesota has a statewide computing network and that's built sort of between
1965 and 1975 and they're very explicit in saying,
we're going to build this as,
as a public institutions to provide a quality of access,
not just for people in the twin cities suburbs,
but for people in rural areas,
for students who are in less affluent areas and they use their weight as the
state government to do things like negotiate better,
fall in line rates and negotiate lower costs so that it really does become a
public good.
Yeah.
So
hmm.
Networking is more widely available today.
Yes.
Uh,
and the cost of the devices is lower,
although a high end,
you know,
smartphone is probably $1,000 these days.
So it's still not very,
uh,
equal access.
But I mean,
do you think that notion of citizenship still is one we should be thinking about
today?
I mean,
right now you are a consumer of like social networking apps and,
and you don't have a whole lot of control over it.
Right.
Would it be better if there were more programmers a citizen?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Think citizenship is something we should be thinking about precisely because we
are consumers.
I mean,
so much of the social media that we consume are,
so many of the apps are made by corporations that are out to make money,
not out to do the public good.
And those aren't necessarily mutually exclusive.
But it's a reminder that if you have a company that is looking after its bottom
line,
that's the bottom line.
Not the people who are using the apps are using the platform or whatever it is.
So I absolutely think competing citizenship is relevant to sort of reimagine
where do we want are very much digital networked world to go,
what,
what would the conversations around what we hope look like and how can the past
inform us sort of in what we might want to change and what we really liked about
what things look like in the 1960s in 1970s.
Yeah,
I tried to think what,
what version of programming is available to kids today?
And I'm wondering like it,
Minecraft is probably the closest they get to creating things,
right?
I don't,
I don't know how widespread otherwise,
uh,
for kids actual creating of things is
there.
I mean I think there are,
there are some pushes and
to sort of get kids back into coding and programming and,
yeah.
But I think too with anything like that,
there's still the same caution of like,
well how,
how are sort of societal expectations around do we encourage the boys more than
the girls are sort of how these things play out.
Right.
At the same time.
Yeah.
Um,
I had one more question I thought I would ask and then try to open it up to
audience questions.
So you talked about a lot of different sort of early computing networks and
systems and users and it,
and it seemed like you had a call at the end of the book that,
uh,
your list is not exhaustive,
right?
It's not like you hit,
like,
do you have other areas that you've heard about or you think that would be
really interesting for someone to investigate more?
Yes,
yes.
So other people,
other historians,
other communications and media scholars,
whoever.
Um,
my book basically ends right around 1980 and I think the sort of the 1980s into
the early nineties is another rich,
amazing time to say like,
all these people were buying personal computers and there were so many computers
in schools.
Like if we wrote those histories from me user up,
what would they look like?
Similarly?
Um,
we know a bit about the,
well while there was a New York City version of that called Echo east coast
hangout,
which was a huge online bulletin board system during the eighties and nineties.
Another great source to look at like what,
what's happening,
sort of what is as more people are networked,
what does that look like?
Um,
yeah,
there's a whole,
I think a whole world in a whole case of the eighties and early nineties and not
just in the United States.
This is the other thing that I am excited about.
Some of my colleagues are writing right now,
histories of networks in the Soviet Union or networks in China,
these kinds of things.
And I think all of those are important to help us understand that the United
States isn't necessarily,
um,
the isolated,
unparalleled case.
But what are the similarities and differences?
Yeah.
All right,
thanks.
So,
um,
anyone else want to ask some questions?
We can.
Hi.
Uh,
thank you for your talk.
I was wondering if you could talk a little bit more about where this particular
work like fits into your professional interest or your personal story or like
sort of how you came to be,
uh,
to,
to want to write this book and put the,
put these things together.
Right.
Yeah,
I love that question.
So I was actually telling Jeremy this a little bit before.
Um,
I am maybe an atypical historian and that I was a math major at Dartmouth.
I was also a history major and after college I worked for a must a decade,
uh,
at companies that involved technology and education or launching programs that
had to do with education and technology.
And every single time,
every single place we sort of roll something out and watch what,
you know,
we called them the users,
like what are they going to do?
And it was never what we expected.
And it was always creative and surprising and sometimes infuriating.
But it was something that at the time I was like,
this is,
this is not at all what I expected.
Uh,
people are doing things very differently in an amazing social often social ways
that we hadn't planned on.
Um,
and so when I finally sort of my path meandered and I said,
it's time for me to go to Grad school.
You're going to pay me to do this,
to read and write.
Yes,
please sign me up.
And I studied the history of science and technology and when it came time to
pick a project or look for our project,
I was reminded that as an undergraduate at Dartmouth,
I was an Undergrad at Dartmouth in the nineties we had this vibrant,
competing culture of email.
I never picked up the phone.
I had other friends who were like,
what's email?
And I was like,
email is great.
Like,
I mean,
right.
How can I tell you what email is if you don't know?
Um,
and I remembered sort of from being there,
I knew that Dartmouth had more of a history.
So that was sort of the first place that I started when I said I think I want to
write a very different history than most,
even within among professional historians,
most computing histories are very much like men and machines.
And that's changing recently but it wasn't the history of that.
I wanted to write.
And the final,
the third thing,
and I sort of recommend everyone,
like go check this out.
There's a great book called Computer Lib.
You can and must understand computers now written by Ted Nelson.
I think he self publishes it in 1974 and in the first few pages of that book,
he has a map.
It's a hand drawn map and it's like where it's at computing USA.
And I looked at that map and yeah,
there's Mit and the like one 28 area.
And of course there's like the bay area and a few other places that I knew.
But then I saw Dartmouth and I thought how high that we're onto something here.
And I saw a Minnesota,
uh,
and I saw,
and those were sort of points for me to say what's going on.
Fair.
Yeah.
So say you had some really interesting looks back at history and how gender and
computing into played,
uh,
and you touched on it a little bit,
but I was curious if you had more information about how race and computing in
the plate back then and how that's changed over time.
Thank you.
That's a,
that's a great question and it's something I talk a little bit about in the book
is,
for example,
and I'll use the Dartmouth case again.
So at this time,
Dartmouth in the early sixties,
Dartmouth has almost exclusively white students and by the end of the 1960s,
as Kennedy becomes president,
they're working hard to actively sort of recruit and diversify,
um,
native American students as well as black students.
And there's this moment in time,
whereas all of these students are coming in,
you can see in the newsletter that they're giving to all the first year
students.
They're promoting a sort of homegrown programs about race that had been
developed to sort of combat racism and to really sort of make people aware of
some of the problems with racism.
But those programs which had been developed in anthropology,
they sort of came with warnings that said like,
oh,
we don't recommend the use of these programs outside of classes for advanced
undergraduates because they could be misunderstood if used the wrong way.
And meanwhile the computing center is like,
Hey,
all you first years check out these programs.
And there I think with all good intentions inadvertently Rayanne scribing the
racism as well as calling attention to the otherness of all of those students
who aren't white men.
And,
and really,
and this,
this also sort of needs to be emphasized doing work of saying,
oh well computing is something we are racist.
Something we can study with computing,
therefore it's separate from computing or it seems separate from computing when
we know that's not the case when race just as much as gender is part of the
social world of technology.
It's not a question,
but it's a little bit of optimism.
Um,
but one of my markers for the relationship between technology and society is
something that I learned from Google.
Uh,
if you do an image search for scientist,
even up to a year ago,
it was all pale males and I just did it just now.
I break my role about opening my laptop's in a,
in a meeting and I checked and it's much better now.
So there's a positive note there.
Someone's working on it and the power of a Google image search to impact
people's view of a field.
It's very important.
And uh,
so there's some,
was a happy note.
Yeah,
no,
there is a happy now and I mean it's sort of,
it's like cuts both ways,
right?
And it's the artificial intelligence and machine learning saying if you asked
for a picture of a doctor,
you get up man.
And if you asked for a picture of a nurse,
you get a woman.
But as my colleagues and I and people here call attention to those things and
sort of increasingly become aware of the,
the responsibility that needs to be inherent.
And like I said,
the fact that tech isn't separate.
Like you're always doing what you do with people in mind and to be more mindful
of who those people are,
if you know it can make a difference.
Yeah.
Baby steps.
Yes.
Uh,
I thought it was interesting you brought up,
um,
the fixation on pipeline today as I would call it a scapegoat,
from actually,
you know,
actually doing some,
uh,
something about inclusivity with the people who are already in the pipeline or
something like that.
Um,
and it strikes me that that's not an excuse you can use an early computing.
Uh,
do you find that there were
similar scapegoat type arguments,
um,
in early computing that,
limited a diversity and inclusion or was it more direct and stereotyped in the
ways that you,
so I'm going to,
I'm going to summarize a lot of history here and the work of my colleagues to
say,
so computers used to be a word that meant people computer,
Pre World War II computers referred to people who did mathematical or with
Matech computations.
Um,
and those people were most often women.
And when computing,
certainly in the United States as well as Great Britain,
sort of when computing became in the,
we'll say sort of world war one,
World War Two era,
the work of business administration,
office machines and people doing computing at that time were most often women.
And it's why in some ways it's not surprising that there are so many women doing
computing in the United States during the 1950 [inaudible] and 1960 is what
we've seen happen is that as it was increasingly clear that computers would be
crucial to society and valuable work,
sort of multiple processes happen whereby women were pushed out because the work
became more PR work seen as more prestigious and therefore as computing
professionalize became a more masculine field.
So sort of aptitude tests were given programmers that really emphasize masculine
male characteristics for instance.
Yeah.
Um,
so
it wasn't sort of,
in some ways it was like a reverse of inclusivity where the women were over time
pushed out and the cultures around technology became more masculine and ways
that it was harder for them to be in that work.
In that world.
We have time for one more question if there is one.
Hmm.
Hi [inaudible] this is related to the previous questions.
Can you talk a little bit about the role,
what you see the role of allyship is in closing some of these opportunity gaps
for minorities in tech at both in the past and maybe presently if you have time.
Yeah,
thank you.
So
I think
being an ally is crucial at this moment too.
Recognize sort of for all of the people who are here around Google and other
companies that we identify as tech companies to sort of look Billy,
do you sort of individual and communal self examination to say what are the
behaviors or ideas or our culture is in a particular meeting in a,
on a particular team,
how might those be?
MMM.
How might those be?
Not just sort of in some ways being harmful to people who are not like you.
Um,
but also how might they be amplifying privilege or,
um,
sort of,
uh,
just creating sort of more comfort for people who are like you.
So I really do think it's this ongoing level of saying,
okay,
I'm here and I want to be an ally.
I want to,
um,
help support and hire and work with and empower people who aren't like me to
enhance more diversity,
whether it's gender or race or sexual identity,
sort of all the things.
Um,
but it's,
it's really a level of awareness of boat.
It's that sort of a,
it's the imaginary user,
right.
And,
and not just the imaginary user of technology,
but in meetings,
in spaces,
mmm.
In corporate worlds as well as sort of the world's created by the technology
that we used.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Um,
yeah,
you can talk to Rankin,
Professor
Rincon,
joy
and Jeremy for moderating.
Um,
we are wrapping up our talk,
but for all of you here,
we have copies of the book that will be signed.
So we encourage you to avail yourself of that.
And thank you very much.